[Musik]
Sicherheit für die Ukraine NATO Stärken
Russland provozieren das ist unser Thema
heute und einen guten Abend natürlich
die Waffen schweigen die russischen
Truppen haben sich zurückgezogen und die
Ukraine steht unter dem Schutz mächtiger
Verbündeter das war und ist der Plan von
wolodomie selensky Sicherheit für die
Ukraine ist auch das Ziel dieser
Verbündeten in die NATO können Sie das
Land vor Kriegsende aber nicht aufnehmen
sagen vor allem die USA und Deutschland
welche Garantien silensky stattdessen
bekommt ob das Europa einem Frieden
näher bringt oder Moskau provoziert
darüber wollen wir reden mit diesen
Gästen
der designierte Botschafter in Moskau
Alexander Graf Lamsdorf
odericht Kiesewetter CDU Außenpolitiker
der AFD Ehrenvorsitzende Alexander
gauland
und Melanie Amann vom Spiegel sie sind
zu Gast bei Maybrit
Illner und die begrüßt Sie sehr herzlich
groß waren die Hoffnungen der Ukraine
für und auf diesem NATO Gipfel in
Vilnius erfüllt wurden sie nur zum Teil
keine Zusage keine Einladung bloß ein
schick verpacktes schauen wir mal
[Musik]
das ist die nato-perspektive für Kiew in
Vilnius
ein großer Schritt nie hat sich die NATO
stärker zur Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine
geäußert außer vielleicht 2008 als der
damalige US-Präsident die Ukraine
aufnehmen wollte Merkel unser Cousin der
bremskraftwagen
diesmal Bremsen Washington und Berlin im
tandemie
ich glaube die NATO ist sich nicht einig
darüber die Ukraine in diesem Moment in
die nato-familie aufzunehmen wo ein
Krieg herrscht
jetzt geht es darum dass wir die Ukraine
aktiv unterstützen bei der Verteidigung
ihrer Souveränität und Integrität und
Traum gibt es aus Berlin ein dickes 700
Millionen Trostpflaster zusetzlich zwei
Patriot Abwehrsysteme und 70 Panzer für
Kia
da schlug der ukrainische Präsident
seinen Ärger über wahre
beitrittsaussichten einfach runter
[Applaus]
die Ergebnisse des Gipfels sind
zufriedenstellend aber hätten wir eine
Einladung zum NATO-Beitritt bekommen
wäre der Gipfel perfekt
Alexander Graf lambsdorf ist bei uns sie
sind gelernter Diplomat und werden in
wenigen Wochen deutscher Botschafter in
Moskau sein Graf Lamsdorf mit Blick auf
die G7 die jetzt die Lösung sind
ist würden Sie sagen ist es eine gute
Idee ist es ein Trick ist es weil es die
NATO nicht werden durfte erstmal ein
Großpflaster nein dass die G7 gemacht
haben ist ja sozusagen ein Rahmen zu
schaffen für eine richtig langfristige
Unterstützung der Ukraine das ist aber
nicht ein Ersatz für die Annäherung der
Ukraine an die NATO sondern es ist
sozusagen ein größerer Rahmen und der
macht deutlich dass die wichtigsten
Industrienation der Welt und das sind
die sieben das ist ja sogar Japan dabei
die keine weitere unterstützen werden
und insofern ist es kein Ersatz sondern
ein Plus zu dem was wie ich finde zu
Recht zum Schluss gesagt worden ist der
Annäherung der Ukraine an die NATO auf
eine Art und Weise wie ist das in der
Vergangenheit noch nie gegeben hat bei
uns ist diese Wetter außen Politiker der
UN Herr Kiesewetter mehr war nicht
möglich für die NATO als diesen G7
Vorschlag zu präsentieren damit eben
erst mal bilateral Länder der Ukraine
die Sicherheit
ermöglichen ja mehr war nicht möglich
aber ist doch eine ganze Menge erreicht
worden mit Blick auf die NATO selbst das
2% Ziel als Untergrenze aber eben auch
stärkere Einsätze stärkere Ausbildung
stärkere Vorbereitung der
Rüstungsindustrie nur der Knackpunkt ist
wenn Putin das Abkommen liest dann weiß
er die NATO war nicht einig bei der
Einladung es gibt keine Einladung und
zweitens sieht er das durch die
mangelnde Einigung eben auch die
Unterstützung Blick auf zwei Prozent
Ziel und so sehr verharrend ist und ich
glaube dass wir hier eine Chance vertan
haben weil gerade Deutschland hier hätte
mehr tun können insbesondere
diplomatisch denn eine Einladung heißt
nicht Mitgliedschaft sondern heißt dass
sie nicht mehr verhandelbar ist und die
große Sorge die nicht nur die Ukraine
hat sondern auch Frankreich ist dass die
Mitgliedschaft der NATO Mitgliedschaft
der Ukraine in der NATO irgendwann
vielleicht doch noch mal verhandelt wird
und diese Botschaft ist nicht ausgeräumt
und das erfüllt mich mit Sorge alexander
gauland ist bei uns eher ein
Vorsitzender der AFD Herr gauland wie
haben sie auf die Ergebnisse dieses
Gipfels geschaut in Vilnius
dafür gesorgt haben dass die Ukraine
nicht die NATO aufgenommen wird
wir sind auch grundsätzlich dagegen dass
die NATO sich sozusagen an die russische
Grenze ausdehnt und von daher ist dieser
dieses Ergebnis
positiv zu sehen wenn Putin sich
anschaut was er eigentlich mit diesem
Krieg gegen die Ukraine erreicht hat
nämlich dass die NATO größer geworden
ist Schweden und Finnland sind dabei und
irgendwann auch die Ukraine hat er sich
dann nicht wirklich an während Dienst
erwiesen sich selbst und seinem Plan
also ich glaube auch dass man in der
heutigen Zeit das zahlenreich Peters des
Großen nicht wieder aufbauen kann und
das hält insofern einen falschen Weg
geht haben wir ja auch als Partei immer
gesagt dass das ein völkerrechtswidriger
Angriffskrieg und dass das nicht geht wo
gegen wir uns aber wehren würden wo
würde ich mich auch gegen wäre ist
dass wir jetzt Russland mit Sanktionen
belegen und dass wir nicht
eigentlich müsste unsere Außenministerin
täglich zwischen Kiew und Moskau hin und
her fahren und sie müsste versuchen ich
weiß sie schütteln den Kopf weg diese
Wetter ist das Gegenteil von dem was sie
denken das ist mir völlig klar sie
müsste versuchen und das ist unser
deutsches Interesse den Frieden
wiederherzustellen ich weiß dass es
schwierig ist wird überhaupt nicht
behaupten dass das leichtes aber
im Grunde genommen müsste jetzt die
Diplomatie einsetzen damit es einen
Kompromiss zwischen diesen beiden
Nachfolgestaaten
zaristischen und das Sowjet Imperiums
gibt es gibt ganz viele Länder die sich
bedroht fühlen darüber werden wir auch
noch reden aber bevor wir in die
Diskussion einsteigen erste Frage an
Melanie Ammann geschätzte Kollegin vom
Spiegel Frau Amann es gibt im Grunde
doch weiter nach Vilnius nach diesem
nahezu Gipfel eine innere einen inneren
Streit in der NATO zwischen den
osteuropäischen Ländern und der Ukraine
auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite manchen Westeuropäern da ist
macron jetzt gerade nicht mehr dabei
aber auf der Bremse haben diesmal Joe
Biden und Olaf Scholz gestanden wie
problematisch ist das dass wir kein
einheitliches Bild ab dass die NATO kein
einheitliches Bild ich finde das sehr
problematisch auch wenn man bedenkt dass
die osteuropäischen Staaten sicher seit
geraumer Zeit auch unmittelbar bedroht
fühlen und sehen durch Russland und wenn
man ein deutliches Signal eine klare
konkrete weiß Beitrittsperspektive für
die Ukraine gegeben gegeben hätte dann
hätte das auch einen unglaublich
positiven psychologischen Effekt
aufstarten
gehabt die in unmittelbarer
Nachbarschaft zu Russland leben
tagtäglich und die eben den Haupt die
Hauptlast auch dieses Krieges durch
Flüchtlinge und anderes tragen und die
Tatsache dass die Ukraine immer noch sie
hat das Wort Annäherung verwendet in der
Annäherung sich befindet diese
Annäherung gibt es jetzt seit 2008 und
noch immer scheint die NATO oder nicht
wirklich in Sichtweite zu sein und die
Ukraine ist wie in so einer Art
Zwischenwelt sowie in so einem Fegefeuer
und und hat eben keine wirklich
handfeste Zusage bekommen wenn dieser
Krieg eines Tages vorbei sein wird wenn
sozusagen es nicht mehr wir uns in einem
heißen Konflikt befinden dann dürft ihr
beitreten also das ist schon das ich
finde auch dass es eher ein Signal der
der Schwäche und der Spaltung hätten
sich viele NATO Mitglieder mehr
gewünscht und ja
ich meine wenn das muss man ja ganz
objektiv sagen in der NATO sind wir
Europäer und es sind die USA oder die
USA sind der größte
Herstellung der Hersteller von
Sicherheit nein aber in der NATO gilt
Einstimmigkeit also sogar wenn
Montenegro sagen würde wir wollen das
nicht dann würde es nicht passieren und
wenn die USA sagen wir wollen ist nicht
dann ist vollkommen klar aber klar ich
meine wenn die Amerikaner die den
größten Löwenanteil der Unterstützung
leisten für die Ukraine sagen wir wollen
eine formelle Einladung nicht
aussprechen und zwar aus dem Grund dass
wir dann ein Prozess los treten bei dem
ja dann in den verschiedenen
Mitgliedstaaten der NATO die Debatten
losgehen auch in den Parlamenten und
dann die Uneinigkeit unter Umständen
noch viel offenkundiger wird als wenn
man bei einem Gipfel sich auf die
Formulierung einigt so wie sie im
Community steht die Zukunft der Ukraine
ist in der NATO und die Ukraine muss
noch nicht mal mehr durch ein
sogenannten membership action plan also
die ganzen Vorbereitungen durch das ist
ausgeschlossen das ist genau
eigentlich schon erfüllt das braucht das
braucht sie nicht mehr dann halte ich
das für diplomatisch klüger ist so zu
machen als das Risiko zu laufen
sozusagen jetzt über Monate in
verschiedenen Mitgliedstaaten und eine
ganze Allianz diese Debatten zu führen
ratifizieren wir da ratifizieren wir
jetzt nicht und dann hätten wir wirklich
ein Problem
nicht mehr ihr seid ja quasi soweit und
andererseits möchten wir uns aber noch
nicht festlegen das ist wirklich wert
ist und wir haben noch ein paar
Bedingungen
es wäre gar kein Ratifizierungsprozess
nötig es wäre nur eine Einladung
ausgesprochen worden sobald die
Sicherheitsbedingungen ist zulassen und
die Einladung wurde nicht ausgesprochen
und Putin kann daraus ziehen es ist
keine Einigkeit da aber warum liefern
die Amerikaner nicht die Argumentation
wir sehen das vom letzten Wochenende als
die Amerikaner sehr überraschend für uns
die Streumunition angesprochen haben und
sie liefern etwas was wir als
Bundesrepublik echten und die Amerikaner
machen das aus einem Akt der
Verzweiflung weil die Europäer zu wenig
an Munition keine weitreichenden Waffen
jetzt fängt Frankreich an und
Großbritannien aber Deutschland nicht
ich wollte Taurus liefern die aus dem
Akte Verzweiflung ich befürchte dass die
Amerikaner ihr weh tut deshalb eingelegt
haben
verhält sich nicht darauf vertrauen dass
die Europäer mehr liefern und deswegen
glaube ich nicht weil sie sich weil sie
sehen dass die Europäer nicht genug
liefern nicht ausreichend liefern wir
sehen ja wie die Prozesse gerade laufen
und ich denke dass wir jetzt sehr viel
tun müssen auch die Bundesregierung zu
überzeugen insbesondere den
Bundeskanzler das bis zum 75-jährigen
Jubiläum der NATO im Juni nächstes Jahr
alles getan wird dass die Europäer auf
Augenhöhe kommen sie haben es richtig
gesagt die Amerikaner leisten zwei
Drittel der militärischen Unterstützung
und faire Lastenteilung wäre wenn die
Europäer auf Augenhöhe geben es muss die
klare Botschaft sein dass die
Mitgliedschaft in der NATO
unverhandelbar ist und der Satz viel
also ich finde wie gesagt ich
interpretiere diese diese Community
anders ich sehe eine Annäherung die so
nah dran ist sie ist irgendwie geht
die Zukunft der Ukraine ist in der NATO
silenski ist beim Gipfel dabei es ist
sogar ein eigenes Gremium eingerichtet
worden wo auf der einen Seite die
Natascha sitzen und auf der anderen die
Ukraine um genau darüber zu sprechen wie
der in die NATO jetzt aussieht also ich
kann diese Unzufriedenheit nicht teil
manche haben ja sogar gesagt man sollen
Datum nennen ich halte das nicht genau
braucht man nicht manche haben auch das
gesagt also ich glaube das was wir hier
gesehen haben ein Gipfel ist wo sie
lensky am Anfang auch aus
verhandlungstaktischen Gründen sehr hart
gesagt wenn wir keine Einladung kriegen
und so aber am Ende des Gipfels gesagt
hat er ist mit den Ergebnissen zufrieden
und das auch in Kiew genauso
bekommen haben und das ist und das auch
natürlich dieser Tweet von selensky vor
Beginn des Gipfels alles andere als
diplomatisch klug war wahrscheinlich
trotzdem heißt es ja auch in dieser
Abschluss Erklärung das da steht ja
nicht einfach nur wir werden dann auf
jeden Fall drüber sprechen oder so
sondern kommt ja noch dieser Satz mit
den Bedingungen die erfüllt sein müssen
insofern finde ich ist ihre
Interpretation da sehr optimistisch weil
weil das natürlich so eine Gummi Klausel
ist und mit der man alles mögliche noch
auf die lange Banken können wir kommen
noch mal zurück zu dem Gedanken von
Alexander gauland das und wie sehr sich
Russland
Haut fühlt das ist auch etwas was die
AFD natürlich immer markiert und sagt
diese Sicherheitsinteressen Russlands
hätte der Westen nicht ernst genug
gesehen und nicht ernst genug genommen
jetzt ist es ja aber nicht nur eine
Frage der deutschen Regierung es fühlen
sich ja eigentlich alle Länder bedroht
durch Russland ja nur das ganze hat ja
eine Geschichte und man muss zugeben ich
weiß jetzt gibt's sofort wieder Einwände
aber
erinnern Sie sich an das Jahr 1990 31
Januar
die Rede in Tutzing wo ganz klar gesagt
wurde von Herrn von genschung also von
ihrem damaligen Parteivorsitzenden wir
denen die NATO nicht über Deutschland
hinaus aus ja die DDR soll einbezogen
werden das war alles klar und richtig
aber es gibt keine
Annäherung an die russische Grenze
nun kann man sagen das weiß ich auch das
ist argumentiert wird wir müssen jetzt
vielleicht nicht gleich in diesen
historischen Streiter gauland sondern
bleiben und der Warschauer Pakt
existierte noch sondern bleiben noch mal
bei den Gedanken dass sich ja nicht nur
Russland und Deutschland zueinander
verhalten müssen sondern dass ich ja
drumherum viele andere Völker auch
bedroht fühlen also wer wäre an ihrer
Seite ist die Frage welche Regierung in
Europa wäre an ihrer Seite an der Seite
der AFD wenn es darum ginge jetzt
möglichst rasch eine die Waffenlieferung
zu stoppen die Sanktionen zu stoppen und
eine übrigens Initiative zu starten
das ist aus meiner Sicht deutsches
Interesse eine Friedensinitiative und ja
das sehen die Polen und manche
Osteuropäer anders die Ungarn sind
wahrscheinlich ähnlich wie wir aber
ehrlich gesagt ich kann nun nicht
polnisch Interesse wahrnehmen es ist mir
klar historisch dass die Polen mit den
Russen eine besondere Situation die
Schweden die finden auch unter diesen
Regierungen sind auf Tiere Seite sie
sind auf der Kia zur Seite das ist
völlig richtig und trotzdem halte ich es
für falsch denn es ist halt eine
Auseinandersetzung in der sozusagen
Konflikte aus der Vergangenheit noch
nicht gelöst sind und ich muss einfach
akzeptieren ich denke an den Ersten
Weltkrieg ich muss akzeptieren dass ich
die russischen Eliten ich will jetzt
überhaupt nicht erfolgreich reden die
russischen Eliten fühlen sich bedroht
von einer direkt an die Grenze rückende
NATO das ist die Argumentation im Westen
wir sind doch ganz friedlich und wir
sind doch überhaupt nicht aggressiv die
wird nicht wahrgenommen so wenig wie im
ersten Weltkrieg sozusagen die
gegenseitige Einkreisung
dazu geführt hat das größere Sicherheit
war das heißt ich halte den Weg
sozusagen die NATO immer weiter nach
Osten auszudehnen für falsch wir müssen
die Russen in einer Ordnung einbeziehen
wirklich dem auch nachgehen glauben Sie
denn wenn sie sagen das ist ein
Angriffskrieg und sogar das Wort nehmen
in den Mund nehmen das ist ein
verbrecherischer Angriffskrieg ist wenn
ich sie da richtig zitiere das Putin als
Aggressor ein Interesse daran hat
einzuschlagen auf ihren Plan also dass
er das jetzt hätte ja das muss man mal
ausloten sie glauben das geschieht nicht
das Problem ist doch es wird immer
behauptet er will die Ukraine Vernichten
von Putin an die westliche Position
gegeben das haben wir immer im Grunde
genommen zurückgewiesen ich weiß man
soll die Natur nicht auflösen ich bin da
überhaupt nicht dafür aber ich muss doch
sehen dass wir seit 1989 seit der
Wiedervereinigung sozusagen immer näher
an die russische Grenze Rücken und das
ist für die Russen eine Bedrohung das
ist eine Großmacht haben auch das kurz
mal notiert und aufbereitet und sagen
genau diese Frage wie viele
osterweiterungen hatte schon gegeben
seit 1999 gab es fünf Erweiterungen des
nato-gebiets gehen Osten
seit dem Ukraine Krieg kam Finnland dazu
und wohl bald auch Schweden das wäre die
sechste nato-ost Erweiterung
stimmt die These dass der besten
russische Sicherheitsinteressen zu lange
ignoriert hat nein das kann man so nicht
sagen weil was wir jetzt gerade in der
Karte gesehen haben da auf dem
Bildschirm zeigte die Lage 1999 man darf
nicht vergessen dass die Länder über die
wir hier reden die baltischen Republiken
seit 1940 besetzt waren von der
Sowjetunion Polen und die anderen
Mitteleuropäer nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg dann besetzt wurden bzw
dominiert wurden und dann ja sozusagen
in der Umbruchszeit also 90 91 die Zeit
über die noch gerade geredet hat
plötzlich so Sachen kamen wieder wie
diese Abspaltung einer Region von
Georgien die dann die Russen befördert
haben die Abspaltung einer Region von
Moldawien die die Russen befördert haben
wo sie bis heute stehen transistrieren
und da sind die Mittel und Osteuropäer
erneut irrsinnig nervös gewonnen haben
gesagt also wenn wir nicht eine
Sicherheitsorganisation haben die uns
schützt dann passiert uns genau das
Gleiche denken Sie mal an den östlichen
Teil von Estland nach war das sprechen
die Leute russisch den östlichen Teil
von Lettland sprechen die Leute
klassisch und wenn man dann überlegt
dass viele in Russland in den russischen
Eliten glauben es gäbe so etwas wie eine
russische Welt also wo russische
sprachige Menschen leben da darf der
russische Staat einfach handeln wir will
dann müssen diese Staaten natürlich
denken in Gottes Willen wir müssen uns
schützen das heißt die es ist nicht so
dass die NATO an Russland herangegerückt
ist sondern diese Länder sind haben
angeklopft in der Naht und haben gesagt
wir wollen bitte den Schutz der NATO
damit uns nicht passiert was z.B
Georgien mal da sind passiert ist das
ist eine defensive eine defensive
Haltung und es ist eine ein Beitritt
sondern defensiven Allianz so aber es
wird für den großen nicht als defensive
Haltung angesehen der Name haben sie
recht aber das ändert ja nichts daran
dass wir das dass das irgendwo eine
Wahrheit gibt sie haben ja gerade gesagt
es gibt eine Geschichte die gibt es das
stimmt und es gibt auch eine
Kommunikation es gibt narrative also so
Erzählungen großer Erzählungen und
natürlich sind viele Menschen in der
Sowjetunion mit dem Feindbild NATO
aufgewachsen und dieses narrativ wird
weiter bedient es wird weiter so getan
als ob die NATO sozusagen in R2 in
Russland wäre noch mal der Blick ins
kommunizier von Vilnius da steht klar
drin die NATO sucht gar keine
Konfrontation mit Russland sondern es
ist ein reines Verteidigungsbündnis wir
sind Herr Kiesewetter noch mal bei
dieser historischen Frage und erinnern
uns an den ersten Einspieler das 2008
Angela Merkel zusammen mit sarkozidi
Aufnahme der Ukraine in die NATO
verhindert hat war das in ihren Augen
ein historischer Fehler muss man
vielleicht auch noch mal ergänzen Fragen
damit wir alle Fragen beantworten ich
will nur geht gleich darauf ein ich war
zu der Zeit im NATO-Hauptquartier und
habe auch mit dem russischen Botschafter
damals wo sind sehr viel zu tun gehabt
das entscheidende aus meiner Sicht ist
dass die Vorbereitung der Aufnahme in
die NATO viele Jahre gedauert hat und es
war Deutschland damals Warner der gesagt
hat bevor auch nur ein Land das NATO
Generalsekretär Mitglied der NATO wird
aus dem früheren Warschau packt brauchen
wir ein NATO Russland war der vor der
Aufnahme begründet wurde auch mit der
Natur Russland 1997 und erst 99 also
neun Jahre später sind die Länder dazu
gekommen und dann noch mit einer
deutschen Auflage die jetzt viele
verblüffen mag mit dem 2%-ziel man hat
damals gesagt wenn Ihr kommen wollt dann
müsst ihr als Transformationsländer die
ja jetzt eben nicht in einem Rahmen
einer Wiedervereinigung sehr viel
geldtransferiert bekommen haben müsst
ihr zwei Prozent für eure Verteidigung
aufweisen und das hat Jahre gedauert und
die Länder wollten es die Graf Lamsdorf
auch gerade sagte um
Investitionssicherheit zu bekommen
Zukunftsperspektive aber auch um eine
gewisse Sicherheit und das war 2008 dann
der tragische Fehler dass die Aussage
Georgien und NATO irgendwann in die NATO
kommen nicht mit einem membership action
plan verbunden wurde also mit einem
konkreten beitrittsplan und wir sind ja
schon Lügen bestraft worden weil man
Russland nicht provozieren wollte dass
sie im Jahr 2008 bei der Eröffnung der
Olympischen Spiele Russland nach einem
fingierten Angriff aus Georgien ähnlich
wie 1939 Sender gleitz dann
einmarschiert ist und eine Dreiteilung
von Georgien gemacht hat und sie auf
Jahre nicht aufnahmefähig und sechs
Jahre sieben Jahre später ging es dann
gegen Ukraine und die deutsche Antwort
auf damals war eben nicht dass man eine
nato-unterstützung Macht sondern die
deutsche Antwort auf den Beitritt damals
war Nord Stream 2 also wir haben zweimal
beschwichtigend auf Russland eingewirkt
und zweimal hat das Russland als
Schwäche gesehen und dann kamen dann die
Vorbereitungen und die nawalnisbahn ist
doch und die verlorenen Wahlen in
Weißrussland wo Hunderttausende auf die
Straße gehen dass die russischen Eliten
sich nicht vor der NATO gefürchtet haben
sondern vor der eigenen Bevölkerung die
Freiheit wollten bei einer weil die
waren auch 10.000 auf der Straße und
dann ging der Druck nach außen los weil
man das Existenzrecht früherer so wird
Republiken schlichtweg nicht anerkannt
hat wie die Ukraine und jetzt ist es so
dass noch meine Frage an gauland das
wird ihnen nicht entgangen sein das
ausgerechnet jemand der von diesem Krieg
in russischer Seite sehr profitiert
nämlich pregorien der Chef dieser
wagnertruppe sagt das ist diesen
Kriegsgrund den aggressiven Akt der NATO
überhaupt nicht gegeben hat vielleicht
hören wir uns das noch mal an weil man
soll ja nicht einfach immer was
behaupten
na du machst am 24 februar haben die
Ukrainer nichts besonderes gemacht
das Verteidigungsministerium belügt die
Bevölkerung und den Präsidenten und
erzählt die Geschichte dass die
ukrainische Seite wahnsinnig aggressiv
ist und mit der gesamten NATO sich
vorbereitet uns anzugreifen
nun ist erfunden die Aggression der NATO
ist erfunden noch mal die Frage wer
bedroht hier eigentlich hin also Herrn
jetzt sozusagen als Zeugen aufzurufen
finde ich nun etwas komisch das würden
normaler das will ich Ihnen sagen weil
es hier gar nicht darum geht was am 24
Februar geschehen ist oder am 23 Februar
sondern das habe ich ja gerade versucht
darzustellen es hat seit der
Wiedervereinigung sozusagen einen
ununterbrochenes heranrücken der NATO an
Russland gegeben und das ist etwas was
die Russen als Welt und groß macht nicht
akzeptiert haben die Amerikaner
akzeptieren seit 1823 nicht das auf
ihrem Kontinent sozusagen Europäer sich
festsetzen
zu verpachten was dann passieren würde
auch in der Kuba-Krise haben die
Amerikaner völlig zurecht gesagt nein in
unserem Hinterhof geht es nicht wir
haben eine Karte von Paris wir haben
tatsächlich Abkommen wo dieses Freiheit
wo Souveränität zu achten sind dass die
Sowjetunion unterzeichnet und Russland
das tun sie ab das ist ein
internationale Regelwerte Kater von
Paris schloßakte von
helsinkiwelt ist nicht so wie die
richtige als das völkerin ist eine
europäische Regelung keine amerikanische
es hat trotzdem ist es ein Unterschied
ob sozusagen Malta Politik betreibt die
USA China oder Russland das ist nun mal
so wir haben leben immer noch in der
Welt der groß und Weltmächte und da muss
ich natürlich sozusagen gegenüber einer
Welt macht die noch dazu Atome macht ist
ein bisschen vorsichtiger sein als
vielleicht wenn ich eine
Auseinandersetzung mit Zypern ja
vielleicht sogar mit der Türkei
kleineren Ländern das Recht ab zu
entscheiden sie sprechen von einer
besonderen Rechte Priorität Russlands
deswegen haben wir die internationale
regelbasierte Ordnung das nicht einzelne
Länder sich das Recht herausnehmen Herr
gauland das ist eine sehr
Prävention der Geschichte nein das
machen sie nicht und wenn müssen sie
sich rechtfertigen und was Russland
gerade macht das existenzrechte Ukraine
mit Völkermord Vergewaltigung Entführung
von 100.000 Kindern
kein anderes Thema das ist und was sie
machen
das ist real,-
wir haben erstmal darüber geredet wie
ist es zu dieser Situation gekommen und
habe ich nur vertreten dass sozusagen
die Nato und das stimmt immer weiter an
die russische Grenze es gibt
entschuldigung da ist die Frage jetzt
von Butcher und so spielt da noch gar
keine Rolle sie haben jetzt mehrmals
diese das aufgefächert und das haben wir
auch alle jetzt verstanden aber der
Punkt ist doch das ist immer noch den
Schritt brauchte das Russland diesen
Krieg begonnen hat Russland hat den
Krieg begonnen am Anfang gesagt
grundsätzlich eine hohle Phrase wenn sie
sagen ja das ist ein
völkerrechtswidriger Krieg gut das kann
man so sagen aber was folgt denn da
draußen und für die AFD folgt daraus
erstmal nichts weil sie letztlich der
Ansicht sind dadurch dass Russland
legitime Sicherheitsinteressen hatte die
hätten respektiert werden müssen und
deswegen dadurch wird dieser Krieg
natürlich schon durch die Hintertür
gerechtfertigt und legitimiert als etwas
das wie eine selbstverteidigungsmaßnahme
ist ja selber auch immer da das ist
letztens sind natürlich auch einen
anderen Situation ehrlich gesagt ich
finde es keine gute Idee wenn deutsche
Panzer russische Soldaten
wie bitte das sind ukrainische Panzer
die übergeben wir an die Ukraine also
wir sind ukrainische Panzer aber es sind
natürlich deutsche Panzer die russische
Soldaten töten wir haben aus gutem Grund
immer gesagt wir haben das gutem Grund
immer gesagt keine Waffenlieferung in
Kriegsgebiete keine Waffenlieferung in
Spannungsgebiete
das können andere Staaten machen und ist
völlig richtig ähm kann man darüber
nachdenken dass es andere Interessen
gibt wir Deutschen hätten es nicht
machen sollen also wir hätten es ist ja
der Gedanke weiter Herr gauland zu sagen
wir hätten es nicht machen sollen ob
unsere Geschichte diese Argumentation
kennen Sie auch sie wissen dass die
Ukraine viel viel mehr unter den unter
der deutschen Wehrmacht
haben
der die Zeit die der Naziherrschaft als
Vogelschiss in der Geschichte bezeichnet
hat entschuldigung wenn ich das sage
also entweder ist es jetzt ganz
dramatisch was wir da an Schuld auf uns
geladen haben dass wir sogar Angst haben
müssen vor Russland oder es ist etwas
was sich in ihrer Rechnung in ihrer
historischen Rechnung als Vogelschiss
aus also
englische Art jetzt mit dem Vogelschutz
zu kommen ich habe ihnen sagen
mich dafür entschuldigt habe da ist nie
sozusagen der Holocaust oder des Nazi
regime das gewesen was ich ausgedrückt
hast und die Kürze der Zeit das war ein
falscher Begriff für die Kürze der Zeit
ich habe mich dafür entschuldigt
mehrmals und muss mir das nicht
ununterbrochen anhören sie sind nicht
bei uns entschuldigung ich habe ja immer
zugegeben dass es ein Fehler war weil
man eine kurze der Zeit nicht so
formulieren kann aber ich habe x-mal
gesagt wir sind und dann bleibe ich
unendlich oder Englisch in ihrem Sinn
wir bleiben bei dem gedank merken dass
sie sagen die Annexion der Krim 2014 war
Anlass für sie sich zu sorgen um die
Großmacht Russland weil sie da
postulierten dass eine
ruhige eine
fröhliche Großmacht eine sichere
Großmacht ist zitiere ich das richtig
ich glaube nicht sie haben gesagt
ein starkes Russland sei immer ein
freundliches Russland hier ist unsere
Geschichte so gewesen ein starkes
Russland sei immer ein freundliches
Russland das würde nun wiederum auch
sagen für uns Deutsche ist das in der
Geschichte so gewesen müssen wir und
dann sind wir jetzt ja aber in der
neueren Geschichte müssen wir also
Russland irgendwas annektieren lassen
damit es wieder ein freundliches
Russland wird
wir können sowieso nicht eine Annexion
verhindern die Krim ist ein schwieriger
Fall
die Krim ist schon deswegen ein
schwieriger Fall weil die Art wie die
Krim zu Ukraine gekommen ist
klar war das irgendwann Russland das
nicht akzeptieren würde aber das ist
historisch auch nicht richtig dass ein
starkes Russland für uns immer nur gut
war und dass das dann sozusagen
Voraussetzung für Harmonie war wenn sie
mal in die Jahre nach dem ersten
Weltkriegen
die Russland muss geholfen 1763 die
haben uns geholfen 1813 wir haben uns
geholfen
bei der deutschen Vereinigung
Bismarck hätte ohne
russische Unterstützung die Vereinigung
nicht hinbekommen und wir haben
1990 wieder mit den Rosengarten 1990
aber ich will diese These ein starkes
Russland ist gut für Deutschland ich
meine 1990 war die Sowjetunion so
schwach das stimmt dass Sie zugestimmt
hat der deutschen Wiedervereinigung nach
dem in den Jahren nach dem Ersten
Weltkrieg weil die junge Sowjetunion und
und und und die Weimarer Republik haben
sich dann zusammen getan vom blinden und
im
also mit anderen Worten ich glaube die
Frage starkes Russland schwaches
Russland ist das eine eine andere Frage
ist doch wo kommt die Stärke eines
Landes her wo kommt denn die Stärke
Russlands her kommt die Stärke Russlands
aus dem aus der geistigen Kraft seiner
Menschen aus der Schaffenskraft aus der
Kultur aus Innovationen aus aus aus
unglaublich riesenhaften natürlichen
Ressourcen dann ist der Erde oder kommt
die Stärke daher dass man Nachbarn
bedroht und jetzt überall der Ukraine
auch noch überfällt ob nun die Russen
die Nachbar mit drohen lassen weg aber
die Stärke Russland kommt von aus all
dem was sie selber gerade gesagt haben
aber dann ist doch und das ist aber
fallen gewesen wenn der amerikanische
Präsident Obama plötzlich von mitmachen
wenn das so ist dass diese Stärke bei
Russland besteht müssten ja jetzt ganz
freundlich sein leider haben sie gerade
das Gegenteil bewiesen aber ohnehin
würde ja ihre Doktrin dazu führen dass
man letztlich das Völkerrecht im
Faustrecht unterwirft also man soll im
Prinzip die auf die Sensibilitäten eines
imperialistischen nach
neuem raumstrebenden Staat irgendwie
soll man akzeptieren sozusagen
vorsorglich weil weil die eben so groß
und so stark sind und dass dabei das
Völkerrecht mit Füßen getreten wird ist
Sekunde
können immer
wir können immer
das Völkerrecht anführen wir wissen alle
aus der Geschichte das sozusagen
staatliche Auseinandersetzungen nicht
immer nach Völkerrecht verläuft das ist
nun mal so und
haben ja Amerikaner als die
libyenbombardiert haben
völkerrechtlich korrekt gehandelt es
wird immer behauptet die Russen sein
dass nur nein Großmächte sind es leider
oft
ein Mandat des Sicherheitsrats der
Vereinten Nationen gab und das haben wir
Franzosen und die Engländer angestrebt
dieses Mandaten die Amerikaner sind
sozusagen Widerstreben und haben sich
damit reinziehen lassen aber ich glaube
es gibt hier eine Kaffeemaschine
der sie jedenfalls von mir wirklich
unterscheidet und wahrscheinlich konnten
den anderen hier auch sie nehmen das
Völkerrecht als ein nice to have das ist
nett das ist da ist aber es ist nicht
die Kategorien der wir denken sollten
sondern es ist im Grunde die die Macht
und damit sind sie im in einer denke die
sagen wir mal aus dem 19 Jahrhundert
herauskommt wo große Nationen
miteinander in Machtkämpfen waren die
kriegerisch auseinander ausgetragen
wurden das ist aber genau das berühmte
Europa der Vaterländer das jetzt zum
Debakel geführt hat wo Europa 1945 auch
durch maßgeblich durch deutsche Schuld
in Schutt und Asche lag und wir haben
uns danach eine Rechtsordnung gegeben
wir haben uns danach in die Augen
geschaut und gesagt wir werden nie
wieder Grenzen mit Gewalt verändern
sogar noch zur Zeit und es war
aber diese diese Grundlage unseres
Zusammenlebens dieses Völkerrecht und
die Karte von Paris hat der Krise wird
er gerade erwähnt die schützt ja die die
die Menschen vor so fürchterlichen
Ereignissen wie wir es gerade in
butzstein ihre Finanzen anders
vorgesehen damit mariopold das ist ja
etwas was Leben schützt was freiheit
schützt was die menschenwürdig ist die
wir in unserem Grundgesetz ganz vorne
stehen haben deswegen ist es wirklich
ein so fundamentaler Unterschied dass
man den auch mal markieren muss denn der
ist wirklich diametral dem
entgegengesetzt was wir nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg für uns angenommen und gelebt
haben so und dann nehmen wir den anderen
Gedanken noch auf um nach vorne zu
gucken ob tatsächlich berechtigt der
Punkt im Raum ist das nicht genug
diplomatische Lösungen gefunden wurden
und nicht hinter den Kulissen vor den
Kulissen genug sich um Frieden bemüht
wird da haben wir hier in dieser Runde
auch schon häufig genug darüber
diskutiert dass es natürlich geschieht
aber es geschah jüngst ohne die Chinesen
sie sagen am allerbesten wie weit wir
auf diplomatischen Parkett sein können
das ja eine der wesentlichen Lehren aus
der deutschen Geschichte seit der
Vereinigung 1990 dass wir aus unsere
Geschichte zumindest gelernt haben die
Länder zwischen Deutschland oder dem
alten Deutschen Reich und Russland und
dann der Sowjetunion ernst zu nehmen es
war ja Deutschland und Russland die die
Souveränität der baltischen Staaten
Polens auch Litauens über Jahrhunderte
beeinträchtigt haben wir waren
Kolonisten und das haben wir aufgegeben
und die Bundesrepublik wurde zum Anwalt
der mittelosteuropäischen Länder in die
Aufnahme in die EU und die NATO diese
anwaltaufgabe hat uns diplomatisch auch
durch Genscher seiner Zeit ungeheuer
Ansehen gebracht denn das ist leider in
gewissen Zeiten den Hintergrund getreten
und jetzt kommt das Thema Diplomatie und
Verhandlungen es war ja vor dem Krieg
eindeutig das Putin gesagt hat die
Ukraine hat kein Existenzrecht dann
haben die Amerikaner nach
Sicherheitsgarantien gefragt dann haben
wir im Dezember vor dem Kriegsbeginn die
Russen gesagt na ja Abzug der Amerikaner
aus Europa Austritt der baltischen
Staaten aus NATO und EU und kein Recht
der früheren Warschauer packstaaten
Mitglied in der NATO zu sein aber sie
dürfen in der EU sein aber alle früheren
Sowjetrepubliken sein genuine
Bestandteil der Russischen Föderation
und dann bist stand eine mords Pendel
Diplomatie von beiden von blinken man
traf sich in Genf das war für uns
Europäern weil die Europäer nicht
beteiligt waren von alleine ist gereizt
Frau
Außenministerin Werbung ist gereist der
Bundes
und Putin hat sie abblitzen lassen und
selbst silensky hat Angebote gemacht
Verzicht auf die krimen Verzicht auf die
NATO-Mitgliedschaft und dann geschahen
Butscher und irpin und der letzte
Vorstoß der Amerikaner im November wurde
eindeutig von narrischkin abgetan indem
er gesagt hat wir haben bereits 18
Prozent des Landes wir bekommen noch
mehr und das ist genau der Punkt das von
russischer Seite auch die sieben
afrikanischen Staatschefs abgeblitzt
sind man hatte kein Interesse am
Verhandeln weil man glaubte das rechte
stärkeren wird das Recht triumphieren
und am Ende muss man nur lange genug
geduldig sein und das ist das Bittere
auch das Bittere an der Haltung ihrer
Partei und wollen wir umgedreht
sozusagen bis zum letzten Ukraine bis
zum vorletzten Russen kämpfen ich meine
Entschuldigung die wollen für die frei
hätte Ukraine kämpfen sie verhindert das
Ausweiten des Krieges auf Moldau und die
baltischen Staaten das ist angekündigte
Kriegsziel ist jetzt nur ein das ist
angekündigt also so wie er angekündigt
hat dass die Ukraine kein Existenzrecht
hat das Sprechen
die AFD davon auch einen flammenden
Appell an Putin zu richten die Waffen
schweigen zu lassen
Bundestagsfraktion noch von ihrem
außenpolitischen Sprecher
was man immer hört ist es muss eine
Friedensinitiative geben es darf von
ihnen die Aussage das darf keiner diesen
Krieg gewinnen das muss sozusagen auf
Augenhöhe verhandelt werden aber einfach
mal zu sagen ihr habt den Krieg
angefangen bitte lass die Waffen
schweigen damit verhandelt werden wir
haben in unserem Papier zu Rheine und
Russland ganz klar gesagt dass der Krieg
aufhören muss dass Russland seine
Truppen zurückziehen muss und das ist
Verhandlungen geben
alles machen muss es ist immer so dass
es sozusagen bei ihnen sind es immer
zwei Kriegsparteien die werden
immer so dargestellt als wären da zwei
Staaten aufeinander losgegangen aber so
ist nicht zwei Kriegsparteien und wenn
ich den Krieg
beseitigen will muss ich zu einem
Kompromiss zwischen diesen beiden
einfach sich zurückzieht das wäre ja
eine Möglichkeit ja man kann natürlich
oder man akzeptiert dass der Adresse
Entschuldigung
Putin hat einen Krieg angefangen wir
müssen versuchen einen Weg aus diesem
Krieg herauszufinden und hat es jetzt
keinen Zweck weder ihn anzuklagen noch
im Grunde genommen zu sagen mit dem darf
man nicht reden das sind alles die ist
ja falsche Weg ja wir hören vielleicht
noch mal Tino Propeller zu dem einem der
zwei Vorsitzenden ihrer Partei der auch
ganz deutlich gesagt hat was er wo er
den entschuldigen sieht
aus diesem Krieg geht die Ukraine ebenso
als Verlierer hervor virusland es gibt
wieder nur einen Gewinner und dieser
Gewinner heißt USA
so da ist jetzt belegt dass Herr
kropalla das anders sieht als sie oder
würden Sie auch sagen der Gewinner diese
Auseinandersetzung ist der Profiteur ist
die USA wie das am Ende ist weiß ich
nicht wie kann ich auch nicht
voraussagen aber natürlich muss man
sehen dass dieser Konflikt eine
geostrategische ein geostrategisches
Element hat und dass die USA natürlich
ein gewisses Interesse daran haben
sozusagen Russland zurückzudrängen die
NATO auszuweiten das ist geostrategisch
aus dem was amerikanischer Sicht ja auch
völlig richtig ich habe
daran gar keine Kritik von
amerikanischer Seite zu üben ich stelle
nur fest dass die deutschen Interessen
unter Umständen andere sind als
amerikanische Interessen aber was Herr
Koala gesagt ist völlig richtig ich
glaube dass der größte Gewinner am Ende
des Tages China also die USA
unterstützen die Ukraine die sich nach
ganz nach nach völlig nach Recht und
Gesetz nach der Karte der Ver
Informationen hier verteidigt und Hilfe
gebeten hat diese Hilfe kommt wirklich
weit überwiegend aus den USA wir
finanzieren ja es gibt auch die
finanzielle Hilfe aus Europa aus den USA
damit die Ukraine sozusagen als Staat
einfach weiter funktionieren kann die
Amerikaner investieren enorm in dieser
Anstrengung der Ukraine wer aber gar
nicht investiert sondern wer nach und
nach sieht wie die wie die Russische
Föderation sich Richtung Osten
orientiert ist Peking also ich glaube
Herr Propeller liegt da völlig neben der
Spur der wirkliche Profiteur ist China
und dann haben wir dazu unterschiedliche
Haltungen vor anderen und fragen uns
noch mal ob der Krieg durch die Ukraine
sowieso nicht gewonnen werden kann weil
auch das ist ja ein Argument zu sagen
dieses Russland ist ja nicht nur groß
sondern es ist auch eine Atommacht und
es hat diese Bedeutung in der Welt
kann der Krieg gewonnen werden und wenn
er gewonnen werden kann warum helfen wir
den Ukrainer nicht weiter das ist ja
jetzt wieder die Frage die an uns geht
also man müsste könnte und müsste
wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr tun
militärischer und finanzielle Art auch
wenn Deutschland schon sehr viel
jedenfalls in finanzieller Hinsicht und
ein bisschen auch in militärischer
Hinsicht tut ein bisschen viel ob die
Ukraine das gewinnt ich ich bin sehr
pessimistisch muss ich sagen ich weiß
nicht wie ich denke dass dieser Krieg
noch sehr lange dauern wird diese gegen
Offensive da kennt sich der Krise Wetter
besser aus als wir scheint ja nicht es
geht schon wieder geht ja schon wieder
um die Waffen also Graf Lamsdorf wundert
sich über die Frage nicht die Ukraine
wünschen sich seit Wochen und Monaten
diese weiterreichende Kurzstrecken
Raketen damit sie sich eben verteidigen
können und gegebenenfalls die
Landesversorgung für die Krim ähm
durchstoßen können von den Staumeldung
wird geredet wir werden um Taurus
gebeten warum kommt es nicht glauben sie
wenn wir der festen Überzeugung sind
dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg gewinnen
kann
also ich glaube dass wir sehen wie
langsam nato-start nach nato-start
einsteigt in die Versorgung der Ukraine
mit Waffen größere Reichweite das kommt
nach und nach wird das kommen wir sehen
es glaube ich bin Storm sehr erwähnt
britisches System also ich glaube das
wird das dass das passiert man muss
vielleicht mal erklären warum das
wichtig ist das hat einfach damit zu tun
dass natürlich schon auf ukrainischen
Territorium aber schon wirklich relativ
weit weg der Versorgungslager für die
Truppen an der Front sind und die
anzugreifen würde eben die Übungen
gesprochen das sind die militärischen
konzentrieren legitime militärische
Ziele und insofern kann ich den Wunsch
auch keine sehr gut nachvollziehen ja
eins dazu muss man überlegen seit 510
Tagen halten 40 Millionen folgt aus
gegen eine 140 Millionen Volk mit das
Ungeheuer durch militarisiert ist eine
nuklear macht mit welcher Tapferkeit am
Anfang hieß es in der Bundesrepublik
noch es lohnt keine Waffenlieferung weil
sie innerhalb von drei vier Wochen
zusammenbrechen und sie sind es nicht
und inzwischen begreifen wir dass wenn
der Krieg für Russland positiv ausgeht
dass er sich ausbreiten wird dann geht
es gegen Moldau dann ist glaubt dann
jemand bei uns wenn die Ukraine fällt
dass wir das Baltikum verteidigen
deswegen war es so wichtig dass diese
Entschlossenheit von Vilnius ja ausgehen
beim Nato-Gipfel das eben diese
verteilungsbereitschaft da ist und ich
bin zuversichtlich dass wir wenn wir
mehr tun und die Ukraine muss einfach
mal vorstellen die schicken Soldaten in
einen Krieg ohne Luftunterstützung der
Deutsche Bundestag würde Truppen den
Einsatz im Ausland verweigern wenn wir
nicht unsere Truppen so schützen würden
und sie machen das jeden Tag haben
ungeheure Verluste und das liegt daran
dass wir zu wenig Luft nach
Unterstützung liefern sprich
Kampfhubschrauber haben jetzt die Polen
geliefert wir werden irgendwann die
Kampfjet Koalition ohne Deutschland 11
Nation sicherlich haben das soll zum
Herbst Geschehen es wird mehr kommen
aber es kommt alles sehr spät und in der
Zwischenzeit verbluten ganze Generation
wir müssen da helfen und trotzdem ist
die Frage kann die Ukraine ist gewinnen
weil am Ende immer die Frage nach der
was heißt denn also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass es einen Weg gibt für
die Grimm zurück zu erlangen ich glaube
dass das gelingen wird Graf
lambsdorff-sprache ist eben an wenn die
russischen Versorgungslinien
abgeschnitten werden und die russischen
Truppen nicht wie Putin den Müttern
erklärt dort besser sterben als ein
Alkoholismus sterben welche Zynismus
sondern aufgeben müssen ist Putin
Schicksal damit besiegelt und ich glaube
unsere Zurückhaltung ist deswegen so
groß weil man Angst hat was kommt nach
Putin und ich glaube diese
selbstabschreckung aus dem warmen Sessel
ist viel gefährlicher als eine massive
Unterstützung der Ukraine das Putin
erkennt er hat dort keine Chance ich
nenne das immer Russland muss verlieren
lernen also die existenzrechte seiner
Nachbarn Anerkennung sondern um die
Anerkennung des Existenzrechts der
Nachbarn in ihren völkerrechtlichen
Grenzen Positives sagen weil ich bin an
einer Stelle ein bisschen in einen Jungs
schon anderer Meinung als diese Wetter
und das ist die Frage der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit des Baltikums das
hat sich ja wirklich dramatisch geändert
durch den Wald besser Finnlands und
Schwedens wir reden ja viel über jetzt
die Ukraine ein Land das nicht
Bestandteil der NATO ist wenn wir mal
auf die NATO selber schauen und was bei
dem Gipfel erreicht worden ist auch im
Vorfeld des Gipfels diese neuen
verteidigungspläne der
Verteidigungsminister hat die gesamte
Ostsee ist sozusagen eine meiner Nähe
kann man zurückgehen bis 1721 bis zur
Peter dem Großen da war es genau
umgekehrt jetzt ist es ich war Schweden
hat jetzt sozusagen eine Revanche für
1721 wenn man so will also das Ende des
Großen Nordischen Krieges also ich
glaube das was was und das betrifft uns
als Ostsee an Rainer ja auch das ist
eine Verbesserung unserer Sicherheit
durch die Stärkung der NATO durch
Finnland und und Schweden mit Gotland
als der Insel die diesen ganzen Raum da
kontrolliert also wenn wir mal auf die
NATO selber schauen das kommt mit mehr
als 2%, das kommt Mitmenschen wirklich
jeden Quadratzentimeter zu verteidigen
die neuen verteidigungspläne relativ
große Einheit in den Kernfragen der
Allianz absolut dann war dieser Gipfel
durchaus ein Erfolg und mehr
Verantwortung auch für die Deutschen in
beispielsweise um die
Sicherheitsinteressen für diese Länder
zu gewährleisten mit 4000 Soldaten die
in Deutschland stehen werden wir haben
ja auch wir haben ja wir haben ja
Luftabwehr in der Slowakei wir
unterstützen in Rumänien wir haben das
in Polen also deutschland leistet
wirklich enorm viel das ist auch das ist
etwas was gesehen und anerkannt wird das
Training hat sich da gegenüber der Nord
Stream das muss man jetzt mal auch
deutlich sagen gegenüber dieser
fürchterlichen Nord stream-phase hat
sich unser Ansehen in Mittel und
Osteuropa wieder erheblich gebessert es
gibt hier und da noch Reibungen wir
haben gerade diese Sache mit dem Panzer
entstand haltungszentrum Polen was nicht
funktioniert hat aber das glaube ich hat
er in politische polnische Gründe aber
Gruppen Großen und Ganzen steht
Deutschland in der ganz viel besser da
als vor 23 Jahren und da sind wir auch
eines Besseren belehrt worden bei Nord
Stream waren wenn ich ganz alleine aber
wir waren am Ende schrecklich allein und
wir haben schrecklich falsch gelegen
sehr so warum war das falsch da sind wir
bei ihrer Position
aber sie hat recht gehabt indem sie
sozusagen den
verhindert hat dass die Ukraine damals
in die NATO kam und sie hat recht gehabt
bei Nord Stream warum ist das falsch
gewesen wir führen
sonst hätte ich sie sofort gefragt sie
sagen es braucht eigentlich keine
weiteren Waffen und es braucht
eigentlich auch keine sanktione
da muss man auch wieder sagen das ist
ein besonderer Plan um zufrieden zu
kommen weil eigentlich ist es eine
Kapitulation aber bleiben wir jetzt
erstmal bei dem Gedanken dass dieses
russische Gas ein gutes Gas ist es hat
ja offensichtlich wiederum auch bei ganz
vielen Völkern eine echte Bedrohung
ausgelöst und übrigens auch uns einen
riesen Schaden beschwert also warum ist
Nord Stream gut sie sagen die würden
sofort wieder diese Leitungen ja ich
sehe nicht warum wir kein russisches Gas
kaufen sollen
es ist ja nicht so dass wir dieses Glas
jetzt nicht mehr abnehmen sondern so das
Russland im vergangenen September den
uns die Lieferung unter dem Vorwand
irgendwelche Probleme abgeschnitten wir
führen einen Wirtschaftskrieg gegen
Russland ist nicht von mir ist von Sarah
Wagen nicht lassen wir jetzt mal wer
angefangen hat aber
stellen wir uns vor der Krieg geht
irgendwie zu Ende warum sollen wir kein
russisches Gas kaufen
momentan ist es unvorstellbar weil die
Leitungen kaputt sind und bei Putin uns
das Gas abgestellt hat im Moment ja und
insofern ist jetzt die nächste ganz
praktische Frage würden Sie denn glauben
dass sie das sofort wieder installieren
könnten wenn sie Bestandteil irgendeiner
Regierung wären glauben Sie denn dass es
möglich wäre als Deutschland Nord Stream
1 oder 2 wieder zu beleben also ich sehe
im Moment ist es kaputt das musste man
wieder herstellen und natürlich müsste
die außenpolitischen Umstände so sein
dass wir nicht ein weiteres
feindschaftsverhältnis zu Russland
hineinkommen aber sie sagen ja jetzt sie
sagen ja jetzt geht's
ja wahrscheinlich der Krieg dann auch zu
Ende aber ich habe nichts dagegen dass
wir von Russland billiges Gas kaufen und
setzt sich und dann sind wir Herr
Kiesewetter bei der Frage das sind ja
jetzt ihre parteise zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt dafür sozusagen auch
Sanktionen aufzuheben und wieder
Normalisierung der Beziehungen wie sie
es werden können
die sich als sozusagen mit einer
Regierung die einen Angriffskrieg
startet die auch Deutschland feindselig
gesundes die uns abschneidet vom Gas
würden sie trotzdem eine Normalisierung
der Beziehungen eingehen und sagen
halten sozusagen dieses Regime
verkündigungsfähigkeiten und wenn wir
eine andere Politik machen wird sich die
Lage auch normalisieren aber das ist im
Moment die muss keine andere Politik
machen dafür natürlich nur wir haben vor
allem Entschuldigung dass in deutsche
Interesse an der Auseinandersetzung
zwischen Russland und der Ukraine ist
eigentlich nur dass wir nicht in einen
dritten Weltkrieg schlittern wollen
dass das nicht unser Krieg ist dass wir
da eigentlich nicht zu suchen haben sie
sagen sie tun
das ist völlig klar sondern wir müssen
aber verhindern dass ein Krieg in
Europa daraus wird das ist das deutsche
Interesse und das verhindern wir indem
wir keine Waffen liefern und indem wir
keine Sanktionen machen sondern
Sanktionen halten wir immer habe ich
auch immer für falsch gehalten das hat
schon 6 1936 in einem abessinienkrieg
nicht funktioniert insofern trifft
treffen Sanktionen immer die einfachen
Leute es ist was anderes ob ich
Sanktionen gegen irgendwelche Leute die
ich die an der Spitze stehen habe oder
ob ich Sanktionen gegen das Volk habe
das finde ich für völlig falsch
das ist ja alles im
Anzeige der Europäischen Union
veröffentlicht dass jede einzelne Person
aufgeführt ganz konkret mit einem Grund
also das ist da gibt's keine Sanktion
jetzt gegen die breitere Bevölkerung
also ganz im
gegenteilweise in Russland die
Lebensmittelpreise in Russland sind
deswegen angestiegen weil Russland die
Einfuhr von Agrarprodukten aus der
Europäischen Union von sich aus verboten
hat also ich glaube gezielte Sanktionen
gegen Menschen die diesen Angriffskrieg
unterstützen und befördern das ist wenn
man und wie gesagt da gibt es ein
kategorialen Unterschied hier wenn man
sagt dass Völkerrecht ist etwas wert
dann muss man auch zum Ausdruck bringen
eine ein Unwerturteil wenn das
Völkerrecht so massiv verletzt wird wie
es hier ist und Sanktionen sind dafür
ein moderates geeignetes Mittel um genau
das zu tun insofern glaube ich ist es
ein ein guter Weg und wir haben 2014
damit angefangen leider mussten wir
Ihnen jetzt weitergehen nach dem
überfallen
wenn man so schnell wie möglich zur
Waffenstillstand und Frieden käme und
sie sagen ihre einzige Intention Herr
gauland ist tatsächlich dass Deutschland
seine Ruhe hat und dass wir billiges Gas
bekommen und einen weil so kann man es
natürlich ausdrücken ich sage habe nur
gesagt der Konflikt zwischen der Ukraine
und Russland betrifft Deutschland nicht
in seinen Interessen nur in der Gefahr
dass es einen europäischen Krieg geben
sozusagen wir sind nicht mit der UK
keine verbündet wenn es Entschuldigung
Liter und via Lettland wir
obwohl ich gegen die NATO aus der
Erweiterung bin muss ich es akzeptieren
keine Bündnisverpflichtungen
es ist halt so eine Betrachtungsweise
als finde ich auch eine sehr
unbismatische Betrachtungsweise
eigentlich als wäre Deutschland
sozusagen alleine auf diesem Kontinent
und als wären nicht sämtliche
Bündnispartner die wir haben als stünden
wir nicht mit denen vereint zusammen
also sozusagen sie verlangen eine
Politik bei der wir uns lossagen würden
von dem Partner
von den Vereinigten Staaten gäbe ist
Bismarck heute würde der doch
wahrscheinlich auch sagen Entschuldigung
mit diesem Russland mache ich keine
Autoren
auf historische Vergleiche und versuchen
noch gar nicht zitiert ja aber das ist
ja sie haben ja die ganze Zeit mit
historischen Allegorien gearbeitet und
unsere weigern sich sozusagen die
Gegenwart einzubekommen
auf was seit 1945 geschehen ist und wir
sehen eben dass Länder souverän sich aus
der Sowjetunion verabschieden konnten um
ihre Freiheit gekämpft haben übrigens
der erste Staatspräsident von Georgien
der erste der letzte Außenminister
Sowjetunion hat als zweite Aktion als
Staatspräsident den Beitrag in die NATO
in den Beitritt in die NATO beantragt
Anfang der 90er Jahre Chef hat naze das
muss man sich mal überlegen warum hat er
das gemacht und zur Lehre der Geschichte
gehört eben auch dass wir die Ukraine
nicht alleine lassen das was sie
vorschlagen ist ein Denken in
interessensohn das ist dann nicht die
Stärke des Rechts sondern da gilt
überall das rechte stärkeren und dort wo
die Zonen sind haben die anderen
Einfluss und wenn sie sagen dass er
nicht unser Krieg wir haben über eine
Million Flüchtlinge aufgenommen 17
Millionen Menschen in der Ukraine sind
auf der Flucht davon 8 Millionen
außerhalb das ist unser Krieg weil wir
Kriegsziel Russland sind Russland
verändert bei uns Infrastrukturen greift
Infrastrukturen an hat auch im Bundestag
Einfluss Agenten die Russische
Föderation Vision ist im höchstem Maße
auch innerhalb von Ländern aktiv skripal
lithymienko und unser tiergartenmord die
Stürze aus der russischen Botschaft noch
vor wenigen Monaten also mindestens drei
Fälle das geht uns an und deshalb müssen
wir alles tun dass Russland nicht Recht
bekommt und dass die Ukraine in ihrer
Selbstbestimmung in der Lage ist ihr
Land zu verteidigen sie hatten vor noch
einen Punkt aber ich will nur noch mal
ganz intensiv unterstreichen es ist
unsere Aufgabe auch aus leere unserer
Geschichte die wir auf ukrainischen
Boden 8 Millionen Menschen umgebracht
haben die wir auf weißrussischen
belarussischem Boden über 3 Millionen
Menschen umgebracht haben dass wir
mithelfen dass diese Länder ihre
Souveränität behalten wir sprechen gar
nicht über Bilder aus ein völlig
unterjochtes System und wenn Putin unter
Druck gerät das haben wir ja gerade
gesehen verhandelt er auch da hat er den
abgewählten Staatschef von Weißrussland
als Verhandler zu kriegen eingeschaltet
deswegen möchte ich schon ein ganz
starkes plädoy machen Putin unter Druck
zu setzen damit er verhandelt ansonsten
hat die Ukraine wirklich noch große
Erwartungen dass wir weiter unterstützen
damit sich Putin nicht durchsetzen ein
wichtiger Punkt
will das nicht so alleine stehen lassen
die muss sagt das Ziel sind
Waffenstillstand und Frieden dieses Ziel
teilen alle dieses Ziel teilen alle der
Punkt ist nur der wie kommt man dorthin
und das was sie vorschlagen die
Einstellung der Unterstützung für die
Ukraine das wäre das Ende der Ukraine
und das wäre kein gerechter Frieden
sondern es wäre ein Diktat Frieden es
wäre ein die Eroberung der Ukraine der
Untergang der Ukraine das muss man das
muss man so sehen Einstellung der
Unterstützung habe ich jetzt nur gefragt
als Teil sozusagen des Kompromisses ich
habe jetzt nicht gesagt das ist aber ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt
ausgerechnet wir Deutschen
sollten keine Panzer liefern die
russische Soldaten
widerlegt worden ist ich mir die Ukraine
war zu 100% von der Wehrmacht besetzt
vielleicht schaffen wir aber noch über
das besondere Verhältnis der Deutschen
zu Russland noch mal zu reden und da
gibt es einen interessantes Foto Herr
gauland von ihnen und Tino propala in
der russischen Botschaft am 9 mai da
füge ich gleich hinzu dass sie gesagt
haben dass das nicht das richtige Datum
waren zudem sie in der russischen
Botschaft waren weniger interessant ist
vielleicht dieser Fakt als zu sehen was
sich anschließend in einem AFD internen
Chat abgespielt
gestern war ich beim Empfangen in der
russischen Botschaft anlässlich des
Kriegs nicht um für Befreiung zu danken
wie die BZ schreibt sondern um die
deutsche Sicht auf Geschichte und
Gegenwart zu erläutern mein Geschenk
eine Tasse mit preußischem Adler für
Frieden und Aussöhnung
und so waren die Reaktionen auf propaler
Street in einem internen Chat der Partei
ihr habt uns ein Drittel unseres
Staatsgebiets geraubt Millionen Deutsche
vertrieben unzählige Frauen vergewaltigt
und das Land ausgeplündert wir wollen
das mit euch feiern
nein wir müssen keine Soldateska Ehren
das waren keine Soldaten das waren
barbarische Mongolen Stürme am Tag der
Schande vor den Vergewaltigern zu knien
geht gar nicht
wenn Herr kopala und sie für Russland
viel Verständnis haben was sind dann
diese Kollegen von ihnen sind es
Russland Hasser die zu viel landserhefte
gelesen haben oder ich weiß nicht ich
bin in Chat-Protokoll nicht drin ich
habe keine Ahnung aber natürlich gibt es
Leute
die
aus der Tatsache dass wir am aus ihrer
Fraktion entschuldigung das ist diese
quasselgruppe das gibt es einfach
Kollege von uns
war das falsche Datum sondern wir hätten
an dem Tag wir hatten ja zwei
Einladungen an dem Tag dem russischen
Nationalfeiertag da hätte man das machen
können insofern war das ein Fehler
ehrlich gesagt das interessiert mich
nicht was Leute alles
interessiert mich trotzdem nicht
entschuldigung wenn ich mich mit jedem
beschäftigen würde der in irgendeinen
sozialen Medium aktiv wird dann könnte
ich es aufgeben das ist ja jetzt noch
nicht jeder noch mal es sind alles
Mitglieder des Bundestages die sind also
in der Fraktion der AFD mich würde
interessieren Melanie Hermann wie geht
das in der AFD das eigentlich beides
nebeneinander existiert in der Partei
zum einen eben offensichtlich die Russen
verstehe und zum anderen die die
maximal
geographische Interessen der den Russen
zuschreiben ja interessant ist ja an den
Chats das nicht kritisiert wird dass
sozusagen wegen des Angriffskrieges
gegen die Ukraine dieser Besuch in der
Botschaft sondern
er wird kritisiert dafür weil das
sozusagen die Leute sind die unser
schönes Deutsches Reich besiegt haben
nach dem mit dem zweiten Weltkriegen
also das ist das finde ich schon
interessant und es gibt in der Fraktion
aber glaube ich schon durchaus auch
Stimmen die sagen wir finden auch den
uneingeschränkten pro russischen Kurs
nicht gut es gab ja auch einen Beschluss
den die Fraktion geschafft hat es gibt
einen Beschluss ihre eigenen Fraktion in
dem steht man soll nicht immer Kritik
los die russischen Positionen übernehmen
steht da wörtlich drin und was war das
andere keine plumpen anti-amerikanismen
und das ist vielleicht auch das
entscheidende das verbindende Element
das viele in ihrer Partei ein das ist
weniger oder nicht nur eben diese pro
russische Haltung sondern das ist vor
allem eine Art wie amerikanische Haltung
aus der dann die Pro russische Haltung
erwächst
was völlig ausblendet ist ja sozusagen
dass sie Wehrmacht in der Sowjetunion
fürchterliche Verbrechen
sie nicht aber dieser dieser Chat
blendet das ja auf einer Art und Weise
aus das ist sowas von geschichts
vergessen die Verbrechen der Wehrmacht
auf dem Boden der Sowjetunion an den
Völkern der Sowjetunion gar nicht mehr
statt sondern Deutschland ist plötzlich
das Opfer des Zweiten Weltkriegs so
einfach geht's dann eben auch nicht